après une petite pause élections
québécoise oblige c'est le retour cette
semaine de notre chronique sur radar
avec mes deux collaboratrices les
affectatrices parlementaires de
Radio-Canada Marie-Hélène Tremblay à
Québec Fanny Olivier Ottawa ON retour à
vous deux bonjour
les cinq dernières semaines on va
commencer avec vous tiens on sait déjà
que Christian Dubé votre demeurer
ministre de la Santé ça c'est clair pour
qu'il puisse poursuivre la réforme qui
l'a entamée durant le premier mandat
mais il y a des groupes qui poussent
fort pour que il fasse avancer plus
rapidement l'élargissement de l'aide
médicale à mourir aussi oui c'est le cas
de l'Association québécoise pour le
droit de mourir dans la dignité donc il
y a interpellé Christian Dubé a peine
une semaine après les élections mais son
message est plutôt passé inaperçu en
fait ce que demande l'association c'est
que le ministre Christian Dubé redépose
son projet de loi sur l'élargissement de
l'aide médicale à mourir qui prévoyait
notamment qu'il serait possible de faire
une demande anticipée pour les gens
atteints d'une maladie neurodégénérative
comme la maladie d'Alzheimer je vous
rappelle le Daniel qu'en juin dernier il
y avait eu étude justement du projet de
loi numéro 38 mais faute de temps le
projet de loi n'a pas été adopté il faut
dire que Christian Dubé l'avait déposé à
la fin du mois de mai ce qui laissait à
peine deux semaines pour l'étudier et
l'adopter alors d'un commun accord les
parties politiques avaient choisi de
reprendre le travail après les élections
évidemment ça avait déçu beaucoup de
monde à commencer par l'Association
québécoise pour justement mourir dans la
dignité parce que justement il y a des
gens qui sont malades et qui souffrent
en quelque sorte et qui ne pourront pas
bénéficier d'une aide disons anticipé
alors est-ce que le ministre va le
déposer rapidement à la reprise des
travaux parlementaires qui est prévu
plus tard cet automne assurément on va
surveiller ça près premier test
on a tous vu la facture d'épicerie
grimper depuis quelques mois ça inquiète
le chef du NPD et jogg meeting se
demande si les épiciers en profitent pas
forcément mettre dans les poches un peu
oui vous savez l'inflation c'est le
thème de l'heure aux communes cet
automne et chaque partie a trouvé sa
façon pour aborder le dossier le NPD a
trouvé le clou sur lequel il entend
taper ce sont les profits des grandes
chaînes d'épicerie Jacques meeting le
chef du NPD a mis en ligne cette semaine
une vidéo dans laquelle il explique son
point de vue vous savez le prix du
panier d'épicerie a augmenté de plus de
10% au cours de la dernière année les
hausses les profits des grandes
compagnies d'alimentation ont également
été en hausse tout ça alors que selon le
NPD il y a pas moins du quart des
Canadiens qui ont du mal à mettre du
pain sur la table alors c'est ce que les
néo démocrates ont appelé en chambre
Daniel la cupidiflation ou la Séraphin
inflation alors néologisme intéressant
alors le NPD a fait adopter une motion
au comité de l'agriculture pour existe
comité-là étudie au fond s'il y a des
liens entre les profits des grandes
compagnies des grandes entreprises
d'alimentation et l'inflation
alimentaire ce qu'on voit dans le fond
dans notre panier d'épicerie il y a
également une motion qui va être dépatue
aux communes pour que notamment la
chambre reconnaisse l'avidité des
grandes sociétés et que cet avidité là
alimente l'inflation et pour condurcisse
les lois pour faire en sorte que ceux
qui profitent de cette situation soit
davantage punie la motion doit être a
été débattue cette semaine et on va donc
être soumise au vote demain
on verra ce que ça donne Fanny Ottawa
Marie-Hélène